thank you for having me yeah I changed
the title of almost every talk I do I
can't help but fiddle and fiddle until
the last minute anyway it's amazing to
be here obviously speaking at track day
is an honor and beyond intimidating so
I'm really pleased to get a chance to
try it today I'm gonna talk about a
project that I did with Trulia it was a
sort of a broad project they realized
that they're you I had gotten a bit out
of control
and luckily they agreed to let me
actually talk to you guys and even show
you some cool yummy data today so I'm
pretty excited about that we did a
project where we sort of reinvented what
a style guide meant for them a sort of
modern version of what that could be
and at the same time we factored their
app to use more efficient HTML and to
move them over to using sass or rather s
CSS for the particular flavor that they
chose so I'm going to talk a little bit
about that about how we you know how we
were able to use style guides as a way
to improve their performance
and to get some other good benefits that
that I think they really liked so first
I have to go back and talk about what
what style guides used to mean and so
this is an example of a style guide that
was done for AOL in 2007 the thing is a
beast it's beautiful it's amazing it's
gorgeous it's like a you know it's like
a piece of art but I would say not
really that useful for the web so it has
things like this with very detailed
diagrams of their logo and exactly the
amount of space that's supposed to be
between each of the triangles and the
actual text of the logo and how much
space should be above and below the logo
and all kinds of things that do not
matter when you're making a website at
all because most of those decisions are
made long before we ever get involved
right
it also contains really super useful
stuff like how the logo should be
positioned on a hat
or they're warm and cool pallets which
you know it is it's beautiful look at
that right somebody spent a fair bit of
time actually making that but what that
doesn't tell me is that top left yellow
am I supposed to use it for type or is
it mental need to be a background color
or is it the color of a box or a
gradient it's beautiful but in the web
world I think not so useful also it's
fantastic that the thesis font family is
warm and intuitive but I don't care I
just need to know when I'm trying to put
something together in the app what font
I'm supposed to use and where and and
how to make those decisions without
having to go knocking on the designers
door every two minutes to ask them
another question about how the thing was
supposed to be built um so what I think
about why these sorts of style guides
don't work is because they take months
to produce they're basically out of date
before they're ever PDF to and put on
people's desks because this is how this
kind of beautiful thing is meant to be
used right it's meant to be delivered to
you like a present or something and I
don't think that that works right
because a design is fluid I mean I can't
tell you maybe people can show me by a
raise of hands a number of times that a
designer has said this is the final
final final design it's never gonna
change after that's right and then a
week later someone's like well you know
that radius could be a little bit
different and so I think that we need a
more fluid and more living kind of a
style guide we need something that works
with code and so oh and the other issue
with them is that they're really
designer centric you know it's useful
for design to talk about what design
means at AOL but it's not useful for
their web team or their engineers to be
a part of the equation at all
so in my opinion we have to kill that
kind of style guide and that vision of a
style guide because it's stopping us
from using something that could be an
amazingly useful tool but isn't because
because it's too limited by what it's
been in the past so we believe in
creating living style guides which are a
little bit different first of all
they're a guide to existing Styles
they're not some pie-in-the-sky wouldn't
it be lovely if our Styles were all like
this their guide to what really exists
on the site at that moment and that's
important because that's the only way
that you can start to iterate is if you
actually know where you're at now
it also lives in code so it evolves with
a site or app this is super important if
you have a PDF style guide it can't
evolve that the site is constantly
changing and responding to new
constraints your app is adding new
features and you know something that
doesn't live in code isn't going to keep
up to date so in my opinion it even
needs to use the exact same partials
that you're using to build out your site
need to be used to build your style
guide that way there's no like extra
step in keeping things going I also
think it needs to be a collaboration
tool for design and engineering to have
better conversations because it feels
like a lot of times we're sort of
butting heads you know we're you know
one side blames the other and the other
side blames the other and it turns out
that like in terms of the performance
equation it's actually a little bit of
everybody's fault and so I think a good
style guide leads to better UI layer
code more informed design choices and a
better performing site which may sound
like a stretch but I'm going to show you
some examples of how that worked at
Trulia so Trulia was the ideal kind of
client to work with on something like
this mainly because they were motivated
to switch to SAS smart engineers really
excited about the project so that always
makes it easier but also they had a ton
of technical debt you know like a lot of
companies I feel like there's this some
kind of like a successful company thing
you get to a certain point where you
have to actually deal with all the
technical debt you acquired to actually
achieve that success and that's sort of
an ideal candidate for looking at a
style guide and looking at a UI refactor
and looking at performance issues
because they have so much to gain from
it not only in terms of the actual user
experience but honestly on a site with a
ton of legacy it just stinks to be a
developer right you're not having a lot
of fun working with that so this is an
example that one of their engineering
managers sent me when we were first
talking about the project about why they
wanted to get involved in it and I know
it's really tiny sorry I just have a PNG
of it but it says I've got the blues and
the reason it says that is because every
single blue on that page is actually a
subtly different hex value
so what Trulia chose to do is to convert
their SRP their search results page
mainly because it was already slated for
a redesign so it's sort of a good
candidate to start off building the
style guide and I'm kind of gonna jump
to the conclusion first so you know why
you should care because I think that
that matters the first thing is to think
about real user measurements so if any
of if you get any take away from what
I'm talking about today and decide to
try a style guide I would say first
thing first you have to have a sense of
what matters to your users and what
matters you know what is the thing
you're trying to improve so you can tell
if you actually got there or not so
Trulia has a bunch of metrics that
matter to them but you know like
Facebook's metric is how closely your
social network on Facebook matches your
social network in real life like that's
excellent right because that really fits
for their business but for everybody
it's gonna be different
it's it's not gonna be the same thing um
so truly have found that their new HTML
was about 48 percent smaller than it had
been before we used a style guide they
had a 21% faster load time this one I'm
particularly happy with 60% faster time
to first byte you know it's the worst
possible user experience when they're
sort of waiting for things to happen and
they have that blank screen with nothing
going on so 60 60 percent improvement
and first bite really made me happy they
were also able to reduce their unused
CSS by about 135 Kb right so that's like
that's more than a site's worth of CSS
that wasn't even being used at all in
terms of their results their search
results page views went up by about 11%
so that's huge right imagine the project
product manager who you could say like I
have this new fancy feature and if we do
it the page views will go up by 11%
they'd be like me me right but if you
tell them it's the feature that's gonna
be invisible and that if we do our job
right no one will ever see that it ever
happened then all the sudden they're
like yeah kind of skeptical right but I
think it's really important to remember
that performance is a feature and when
we do things that improve performance
particularly in the UI layer we get
really good user benefit and and it
behaves like a new feature I found this
one interesting too this is actually
their property detail page
and their pageviews went up by about 3%
what's interesting there's we didn't
touch that page it just happens to be in
the flow to get to to get from the
search results page right so even if you
can just fix your top three pages in
your site you can still get look across
the board improvement in performance um
truly also cares about some other things
click throughs leads customer
satisfaction and stuff like that and
that's gonna be different for everyone
what you care about you don't but every
single one of those metrics actually
bumped up after we started refactoring
their site and implementing a style
guide so you might kind of wonder if
what does a style guide really have to
do with this I think the important thing
is that CSS actually is responsible for
a ton of performance issues it blocks
progressive rendering that's your blank
white page until finally everything
shows up it pulls in a ton of background
images and if you've ever looked at a
waterflow you'll see that a good chunk
of what's happening on the web is
actually images and content images aside
that's a little bit different like
that's a decision about you know where
you want your product to be or something
like that that's probably not my not my
domain but if it's background images
that's something when you can really
make a big improvement
CSS also correlates directly to render
speed and it's gonna slow down your
JavaScript and not necessarily in a way
that you can be like that there that
piece of CSS that slowed down my
JavaScript but more in a way where like
you click on something and it's just not
instantaneous you know it's like a I
don't know just sluggish I guess it also
can cause janky scrolling and animations
and that can be important too because
there's nothing worse than something
that's supposed to slide smoothly and
actually jitters its way across the
screen so a style guide can really help
with this what we want to have is this
like imagine we needed to have a rubber
ducky component in our app and this was
exactly what we needed we needed a blue
eyed orange beaked rubber ducky um this
makes a lot of sense but what we often
have is much more like this right
we have proliferation of rubber rubber
ducky components until we end up having
a something that just doesn't really
make sense
um so the first thing to do and I've
talked about this before so I'm gonna go
over it pretty quickly but feel free to
see me afterwards if it's something you
haven't heard about before and oh and
I'll get more into it but the first
thing you need to do is know what kind
of duplication you have because that's
gonna be your clues for what missing
abstractions you need right everywhere
that you find that your CSS is growing
larger accidentally means oh crap
there's an abstraction that's needed
here that people don't have so they're
writing it over and over you can use
grep CSS lint has a secondary branch
that'll do some duplication stuff where
there's a new ruby gem out called CSS
CSS which is a good way of figuring out
what your your duplication was for truly
oh we used grep it's easy it allowed us
to include like all sort of the most
crufty CSS because the more you put in
the better you'll get a sense of what
kind of bad duplication you have and
where your abstractions are missing um
so we grep for various selectors
properties and values and a bunch of
other stuff we also don't worry about it
being perfect we just think about orders
of magnitude so this is roughly what
we're doing we're you know concatenate
in all the CSS together and then we're
running a very simple grep command now
you can imagine that you could replace
font size with some fancy regex that was
going to make sure that there wasn't
font size in a selector name or
something like that I wouldn't bother I
don't think it actually matters if you
match you know a few extra elements then
you then you should have if a hex value
looks like an ID it just it honestly
doesn't matter it's an orders of
magnitude thing so here's some of the
data that Trulia let me share and just
super super cool that they did take a
look at the margin and padding
declarations so they've got three
thousand nine hundred ninety three
margin declarations in four thousand
four hundred and also ninety three
padding declarations that's so high
right but that's actually fairly typical
for what we find when we start digging
into a UI that's been in existence for a
few years and I see a few of you shaking
your heads that I would say go grab your
own style sheets before you judge you
might be surprised at what you find
again headings too and font sizes like
those numbers they're they're high but
they're they're just so much higher than
they need to be
to make a good UI that UI layer that's
easy to work with another one that I
always grep for is pound important right
because this is like I don't know it's
like the canary in the mine right the
number of importance that you have is
basically like people are getting to the
point where they can't get done what
they need to get done and so they're
like I'll just throw that in there and
we'll see what happens
truly I had about 500 importance and
that said to me like this is the moment
we have to refactor this now it
shouldn't wait even six months yeah and
so there's some other numbers and I'll
you know I'll post my slides later so
you can check out the details so the
other thing that we look for is not just
code duplication but design and
consistency often they'll be you know
hundreds I mean for typography it'll be
like three or four hundred different
ways of having text treatments on the
page
there's no way to build that efficiently
in code if you're given designs that
have that many variations so we actually
built a typography tool that allows us
to find those variations and I'm going
to try command F one and see if that
works so we built a tool and it's right
now a Firebug extension though we're
we're definitely going to move it over
to Chrome so we go into the Trulia web
page and we click persist so that we can
do several pages because this is again
the kind of thing where you're going to
want to have a lot of data not a little
because it helps make decisions then you
click generate report and it's gonna
show you and I know it's really small
sorry about that but all this stuff in
the middle doesn't matter at all on the
right hand side it shows you the actual
font and the the wording that was found
I mean that in the left-hand column it's
gonna show you account for how many
times that was found and then if I do a
search and get to the search results
page I can generate the report again and
then you know we would do it for
multiple pages if we were doing it on an
actual site what's really cool about it
is that you know I've had a lot of
conversations with designers that end up
feeling kind of unproductive where we're
trying to say okay you can't have all of
the typography you have to pick some it
turns out if you put five designers in a
room and you say do you want 13 pixels
or 14 pixel font size they can debate
that for like
I do not have more but if you say do you
want 13 pixels or 14 pixels and you've
used 13 pixels 1400 times and you've
used 14 pixels 23 times all the sudden
there's data to back up those decisions
they don't have to have you know make
these amorphous and we wouldn't make
decisions without data right so but we
can help them have the data that they
need to make the decisions that they
have to make so that's something that's
worked out well
okay and so the output of that is you
know a bunch of font sizes with their
counts and really super useful for
making decisions we also break it down
by color in their counts you know you
could spend days debating which is the
exact right shade of blue but when you
see that one of them was used thirteen
hundred times and the others just a
handful all the sudden the the blue
decision is is quick like that right so
that's that's where we're trying to go
and you know what even if they decide
that they actually are trying to move
towards something that isn't isn't where
the site is at now so they're saying
well maybe we want that bright blue even
though it's the least used now because
that's where our design is going then in
the engineering side you have an exact
map of every time I find these five
blues I should replace it with this blue
and you don't have to have that back and
forth discussion with design every
single time you're trying to make an
improvement to the performance um so we
basically use some heuristics and some
common sense to break it down and give
them a list of the different typography
they need and this is simplified
obviously this is going to be for all
the different components of the site but
they get that and they can use that we
also do it for buttons and so this is
all the buttons that we found on the
Trulia site right which is really really
a lot like that it's just way too many
shades of yellow and green and and blue
and it's like every product manager just
decided that they were gonna do their
very own thing and luckily nobody made
anything blink or magenta but it was
pretty close so for each of those we
basically sit with design and have them
make some decisions for each thing they
can choose to build it they can choose
to replace it with something they've
already decided to build or as a very
distant third they can choose to
redesign that thing we try not to choose
the redesign option because it's far
better to say let's just build it how it
is now and then we can iterate with
something real rather than have like
long drawn-out design discussions about
where the meaning of the button is that
kind of thing um so you want to do this
for all different component types and
when you have you'll have something like
this style guide
so this is oops there we go so this is
the this is the Trulia style guide that
we built and so you'll see it's got you
know all the different kinds of
typography it gives an example of
exactly what you'd need to put in the
code in order to achieve that look and
feel and so it becomes like little Lego
right you're grabbing one of these and
you're combining it with one of those
and you put it all inside of a box like
that and you can build whole different
UIs that nobody planned on just by using
these existing little pieces of
functionality and so if I click on
buttons you'll see that they were able
to simplify down to oh and a at the top
we tend to list all the different class
names so that it's real clear to
everybody what every piece of the UI is
for and so then you'll see they were
able to simplify down just into a
primary button default button and then
this sort of reddish danger button for
delete and things like that so just by
making these kinds of decisions they
were able to really make it work better
for them honestly there are tons of
different component types including like
whitespace classes and tabs and toggles
and all the normal stuff that websites
are made out of one important thing to
keep in mind though is that you want to
separate out the code that's for making
your button have button as' which is you
know solving all the ie bugs removing
all the weird styling that that you're
gonna have on buttons by default and put
that into one class and then anything
that makes it red or orange or whatever
you want to put into another class it's
sort of a worst case scenario where
you've stuffed all that into one class
and then every time you make a new kind
of button you're having to say yeah but
it's not like that yeah but it's not
like that
that's a lot of work and will lead to
pretty inefficient code
okay cool so that said how do we build a
component well what's what's part of a
component how is that going to work we
have a specific component structure and
part of the reason why we have it this
way is because we want to break the
dependency of styles on views basically
when you tied it what did I do
oh so basically when you have when you
have your Styles dependent on your views
there's no way for your CSS to be
efficient at all so we kind of try to we
could try to break that that link so
what we have is a components directory
and inside of that we're gonna have all
the different kind of components boxes
and form pieces and grids and lists and
links and everything separated out that
way if later in one of those turns out
to be unnecessary it's super simple
because it's very self-contained and
everything you need to make a component
is is right there
we also found we'd like to have smaller
files and I have to admit I went kicking
and screaming to this because I kind of
like to have everything all in one place
and just kind of keep it all in my head
and then my team grew and I realized
that's ridiculous and we had crazy merge
conflicts and so breaking things out
into smaller files made that a little
bit easier and so this is a snippet from
the Box component you'll see that we
have some sass for it and we have a
small handlebars which is just the
partial to make a box and then we have
another handlebars which is its
documentation and then we have a skin
folder where we put in all those little
like colors and borders and and stuff
like that so keeping things a little bit
organized some components are going to
have associated JavaScript a lot of them
don't but some will and so we keep that
in the component folder as well we tend
to have a component named Jas and then
just saw a small file which is anything
we need to initialize that particular
component just trying to keep things
clean I think there are a few places
where we've made mistakes though I don't
love having all the skins be in separate
files often they end up incredibly
simple so it feels like a lot of
overhead to have those all be separate
on the other hand if you're going to do
some kind of fancy build process where
you make sure stuffs being used before
you build it into your style
Sheetz having it separate could be an
advantage so we basically and this is
this was a terrible idea we have a giant
JSON file that references all our
components and it's a huge pain in the
butt to work with and if a comma gets
left out it's it's not working very
nicely so we're gonna find a better way
to do this which may just be smaller
JSON files per component or something
like that but that's one part that I
think we definitely haven't solved that
well yet we also import our component
SAS files all into one larger one that
we do separate out stuff related to
spriting because it's a bit slower and
we set up watchers to build everything
automatically whenever the handlebar SAS
or JavaScript are changed that was just
basically a it stinks to have to
constantly be saving this and reloading
things and all that kind of thing so it
saved us a bunch of time you're probably
pretty comfortable with Watchers and
build processes and templating so I'm
not going to spend a ton of time on that
I don't think that would be as much of a
value add as as sort of talking about
how we structure our SAS and to begin
with that I need to tell you how I
screwed it up to get started so the
first thing was trying to make a gray
rounded corner box and sort of realizing
that sometimes your SAS output is a lot
larger than you might think that it is
that said I love SAS I wouldn't go back
and we were able to make these
performance improvements using SAS on
the site but we did have to be sort of
constantly vigilant and checking the
output and making sure that SAS wasn't
outputting something crazy because we'd
combined things we didn't realize so a
box is gonna need a clear fix right
because you don't want
if something's floated inside the box it
just stick out the side or and you want
it to trap margins and and things like
that so we need both clear fix and
actually new formatting context so let's
think about what includes this is this
is an example of a mixin to include over
float clear fix and this is the
overflow:hidden overflow:visible zoom
one there are a ton of different ways to
do clear fix this is just one of them
and so then I can say below in my cool
thing at include clear fix overflow and
I'm automatically going to get all those
property value pairs from clear fix
copied down into my cool thing now I
think you can imagine how this goes awry
when you have my cool thing 1 2 3 & 4
and you end up copying those property
value pairs kind of all over the place
especially in big teams especially when
it's not all next to each other like
that it definitely happens that we end
up with a lot of sort of property value
pair duplication and it doesn't me
sometimes that's still going to be the
right choice it's just about sort of
being aware of it and making sure that
it's the right trade-off in terms of
file size and maintainability next up I
want to talk about making tabs and and
how I definitely screwed up making tabs
so in the oCSS world tabs are just a
kind of box and so I would just say tabs
add extend box in SAS language in order
to get all of a sort of box goodness
without having to rewrite that and then
I started writing the code specifically
for tabs and I went a little bit nuts um
it feels so good to make your SAS match
your match your HTML exactly I'm like oh
my god this is awesome which is
ridiculous because I'm the queen of
teeny-tiny selectors right but look what
this output it it's terrible right so I
saw this and I'm like oh wow right
because you know there's only one a
inside of that's basically making a tab
I didn't need to say box head tab
control Li a like that's such overkill
that's not the selector that we need it
all but for some reason writing SAS at
least for me it felt really really good
to do this so I have to sort of
constantly watch myself and keep the
result file open in another window so
that I'm aware of my sort of bad habits
another thing to notice is that SAS will
output your line numbers and your and
the file that it came from which is
super helpful for debugging as well in
the chrome dev tools you can actually
get it to follow back the chain and give
you the actual SAS file which is really
useful so yeah super tempting to make
the SAS match your HTML don't do it it's
a really bad idea the SAS community came
up with something called the inception
rule and that
to never go more than three levels deep
and I think this is pretty good rule I
would say two to three levels deep is
probably as far as you want to go in
most cases but yeah I think that's
that's a helpful rule so how do we use
SAS and also have good architecture the
first thing is to build simple
components first you're going to use
those simple components when you're
making the more complex ones so people
often want to like jump in and like
build tabs and accordions and all kinds
of more complex UI stuff but it's better
to save that until later we start with
something like this it's a variables
file and we look at it as kind of a
configuration file for our SAS
now you'll see warning warning warning
never use this in your code this is
because we do two layers of SAS SAS
variables I don't like the idea of using
like a dollar blue class throughout all
of my SAS because like I said final
final final design never seems to
actually be the final design but we
still liked the the power of getting to
have these names which described exactly
what we were getting out of it so we
decided to do a two tiered approach to
SAS variables the first one is this
where we define all the basic colors and
give them color names that match exactly
what they do but rather than using these
inside the inside the components
themselves what we do is create this
next level so this is four links and we
have link color and that would be dollar
blue and we have link hover color and
that would be dollar green and that
allows us to basically have the the nice
easy readable thing and the consistency
right because we know we're not going to
have a hex value in there that's
slightly different but it doesn't pepper
our style sheets with variable names
that are incredibly likely to change
later so we do that for a bunch of
different typography and we're using all
the data that we're getting out of the
of the component finder typography tool
to end up building that so we do
something like this where we have you
know our h3 and we're going to include
font size of 24 pixels one thing we
found is that we're really loving
working with REMS but
it's a pain to be perfectly honest I
don't want to be constantly thinking and
calculating and not knowing what I'm
getting out of it and so a girl who I
work with Mobe whale on Twitter actually
created these these mix-ins which have
been really helpful for us it's a font
size mixin and a calculate REM mixin
this means that we can just input pixel
values and it outputs the most modern
version that we can with a pixel
fallback and so we found that this is
super helpful basically in the code you
say @include font size of 16 pixels and
that's going to both output 16 pixels as
a backup value and output the REM value
for better browsers that can support it
so we do that for all different kinds of
things I think at first we've sort of
focused on colors and stuff like that
but more and more we're pulling
different things out of out of our files
and putting it into variables it ends up
feeling like it ends up feeling like a
big configuration file where you can get
things to turn out without making very
many changes and in fact I think one of
the things that Trulia designers really
liked about it is that they saw this
variable file and felt like they could
really dig in and you know they're like
wait I'm gonna change the color gray and
started actually submitting pull
requests which is awesome right because
there's no reason to use engineering
resources for you know a change in a
color gray but if they'd had to dig into
the deep components in order to do that
they might not have felt like they could
so that was pretty awesome so we also do
things like declare the baseline height
and base font size base font family
things like that and those can be used
by other other components later that
want to be you know doing vertical
rhythm and stuff like that so we do it
for lists as well
lists are super important and they're
like you end up having more or less than
pretty much anything else on your site
and so yeah like that list up there
homes for sale it's got a little gray
line in between the items that list is
on almost every site in the universe
right it's just the color gray of the
line will vary so there's a lot of this
stuff I kind of feel like about 80% of
all apps and sites are the same and then
there's like a thin little layer which
is actually what makes them them look
different um so we do it for links as
well so they ended up with
default links and low-light links and
forward links and backlinks and now they
have those and they can plug them in in
different places and make stuff out of
them without needing to reinvent the
wheel and recode their link color
everywhere so we have a little
teeny-tiny handlebars file per component
that just basically applies the class
names of all the different skins so that
it can output properly to the library
and then we're gonna again have
variables for links so that later if we
want to change them there's no need to
like really dig into the into the
component we also found that it helped
to build three different layout
mechanisms one wasn't enough and I think
a lot of people will be like oh do you
like grids or do you like inline and I
say I actually think you need both in
different contexts so we build grids a24
based system this is super useful like
if you have a lot of floats and
positioning and widths in your in your
CSS when you go and grep it that means
that you need a grid system probably
rather badly and so having a grid system
means that people who don't necessarily
understand every in and out of CSS
layout can start making new cool pages
without having to get exactly how every
bit of CSS works so the way that we did
that shoots getting cut off at the top
but I'll tell you about it and we
created a grid where you can input the
number of columns that you want because
we found that from site to site it
actually varied and some people were ok
with 12 but a lot actually needed 24 we
had one request for 61 but I said no
because it's divisible by approximately
nothing umm so yeah the number of
columns are gonna have is going to vary
and so this takes two parameters number
of columns and your gutter size and so
those are those are things that you can
basically output any grid system you
want and those again are in variables so
that you can change them without needing
to muck into the guts of how that
component is working finally we also
have a media block which lets you layout
images with text and an inline list that
lets you layout things when you need
vertical alignment and so with those
three pieces of layout you hardly ever
have to write anymore floats again
the biggest thing with style guides is
that you're making it easier to do the
right thing than it is to do the wrong
thing people are always going to have a
tendency to go back to views based CSS
anytime they can because it's the
comfortable path it's how we've been
doing it for a long time but having a
style guide helps break that connection
between your view and your button so
that your button can live in a modal or
it can live in a page or really anywhere
that you need it to so the takeaways are
that well clearly this was a group
effort a lot of things change to make
these metrics move design style guide
SAS UI layer improvements as well as a
bit of server-side cleanup and I think
the other takeaway is that SAS really
can be made to be performant we just had
to be super vigilant about what the
output is going to be like and make sure
it makes sense to be sending that over
the wire and finally good performance as
a feature if you can get an 11%
pageviews bump from just a page that
that's changed performance wise I think
that that's well worth taking to a
product manager and having a
conversation about all of the code that
I talked about is available on github
it's under oo CSS under my username
stubborn Ella and I will tweet and post
the slides so that you can get that URL
later thank you very much